here's what would happen if you touched
absolute zero
at minus 273 degrees celsius absolute
zero is the lowest possible temperature
in the universe
let's say we froze a small piece of
metal down to absolute zero well as you
pick up the piece of metal you'll find
that it's absorbing all the heat from
your hand
your hand is covered with moisture and
as the water freezes inside the tiny
pores of your hand
if you try to remove the piece of metal
the flesh on your hand will rip right
off with it
next blood vessels near your skin will
begin to constrict this will reduce the
blood flow to the affected areas and
help keep your vital organs alive
the piece of metal will lower your
cell's temperature until they are so
cold that the liquid inside them freezes
this will create sharp ice crystals
inside them and damage the structure of
your skin cells
eventually you'll get fourth degree
cryogenic burns on your hand and this
will lead to gangrene and extensive
necrosis
with your injuries there's only one way
to save you amputation
so